the best ensemble cast in the new
scripted series is the cast of
reservation dogs
okay so yeah congratulations devry
jacobs de faraway natai lane factor
paulina alexa sarah podemski zahn
mclaren little mike and funny bumble
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you so so much film independent
for recognizing us with this award we're
so grateful and honored to stand on this
stage alongside artists who we respect
and admire so much but we're especially
proud to be in the same room with our
fellow indigenous nominees lyle janna
michael kaylee and chaske
[Music]
this prize is so much bigger than
ourselves just ourselves each of us come
from different nations across turtle
island who survived 500 years of
colonization and in the hundred years of
film and tv reservation dogs now marks
the first project with all indigenous
creatives at the helm
[Music]
this is an ensemble cast and there are
so many res dogs who deserve the
recognition but can't be on stage with
us today from our little brother elaine
to dallas gold to to little mike and
funny bone alva jew jack and so many
more we share this award with you
and
to our leader our uncle our cousin
sterling harjo you created the show that
all of us desperately needed to see
growing up but couldn't have it you've
given us a chance to laugh to mourn to
heal and to celebrate with our
communities and capture it all on screen
mado
thank you to fx
taika
our talented team of writers and
directors kate dean
angelique mid thunder
those who found and catch
cast each of us
thank you to the muskogee nation
and our phenomenal crew members to the
tongva nation who hosts each of us here
tonight in their traditional and
rightful territory
thank you
[Music]
thank you to all of our families and
community members back home
and to all the res kids
and all the daniels i never got to
we love you all and we hope we did you
proud
to all those who came before us working
in hollywood playing antagonists in
western movies and mythic stoic and
savage indians to native creators who've
had to endure and break down tropes in
this industry we are here accepting this
award because of you we are walking on
the very path that you fought for us and
carved out for us we hope that this
could mark a new beginning native
artists have so many stories to share
and we're only beginning to scratch the
surface
boa thank you so much
[Applause]
[Music]